excellent to be back in my original
hometown of of london
at pie data in person again
i do have too much material um but we're
going to turn that into a virtue and
turn but various things into exercises i
didn't know i was going to have too much
material till i tried doing it
so i'm sorry about that i'm going to try
not to waste too much time
um we're going to be talking about
parallelism and in particular mpi and
mpi for pi today
i think uh
it's a pretty important topic and if you
even if you don't end up using it i
think it should help you understand
what's going on in
um in in parallel systems today
hopefully everyone got the email with
the instructions about what you need to
install to do the
sort of type along stuff here so you
need a working mpi for pi which means
you have to have installed
a copy of mpi if you haven't you're
probably too late but what we'll do is
when we start the exit well maybe i'll
do a show of hands maybe i'll get to a
point where i can see people
who has a working mpi for pi
right i was thinking we could like pair
up or something like that so but it's
looking like it might be more
okay well um okay that's uh
well that'll be interesting when we get
to the um to the practical part um
yeah maybe i'll maybe i'll
[Laughter]
maybe i'll show you more than we'll do
the trouble is we can't we can't do the
installation now because the
installation could take anything up to
an hour for each person and if i go
around helping people install one at a
time and we've got an hour and a half
it's it's not going to work
if i could do it in parallel and do all
of you at the same time that would work
but given that you don't all have
identical systems and identical levels
of experience that's not going to work
um okay let's not waste more time we'll
get on don't worry about it we will make
it work yeah i see
i got the email um
i don't know
if it is maybe that will help i don't
think so because i
but it's i guess it's possible
okay let's let's without
too much further ado so the slides are
available from this url if people
haven't got that in case anyone can't
read it at this scale they're also
available from github so there's a repo
that you should download you should get
clone
this thing here which has the code
examples and the slides in it and that
means even if you
don't have a working mpi for pi you can
get yourself a working mpi for pi
afterwards and try all the examples
i strongly recommend that well
i was going to strongly recommend that
you type the examples because i think
you really learn something by typing but
um
yeah maybe you'll learn something by
typing even if you can't run them if you
don't have don't have installations um
you should also be familiar with the
documentation for mpi for pi which is
the library we're going to use
which is available from that that second
url
and
mpi pi has a set of examples with it in
the tutorial and i have reworked a
number of those examples and i think
made them clearer and better and you can
also clone my enhanced versions or at
least what i claim to be by enhanced
versions of those
from that second url
now i didn't really think this through
because i can't really leave those up
and move on to the next bit
oh well yeah so
uh i'll i will leave that up and just
just talk a moment so there are parallel
computing is a huge topic parallel
computing has existed um for
i don't really know how many years but
certainly since the i mean i started
doing it in the 80s
and i wasn't the first person to do it
so it's at least 40 years old probably
more and basically all computers are
parallel now and there are lots of
different abstractions and lots of ways
of taking advantage of parallel
computers
um
i guess i'm going to hope people have
got that there are lots of words around
around this that you will have seen i'm
not going to read through them all and
we're not going to cover all these the
ones you most like to hear in python are
the gill which should probably be in
giant letters because the gill is the
big problem for parallelism in python um
if you use mpi in the way that i'm
talking about the girl doesn't matter
the kill is not an issue anymore we're
not going to talk about a cinca or async
away or any of that sort of stuff
um the stuff we're going to concentrate
on is the stuff in red if that looks red
from where you are
yeah the sort of
yeah that really didn't work did it uh
well we're going to we're definitely
going to create on the dark stuff and
the bits that do look a bit redder if
you downloaded the pdf
that's a little bit disappointing anyway
um okay so what is parallel computing
parallel compute sorry i should say
we're going to start there's going to be
about half an hour of chat i'm going to
try very hard not to run longer than
that and then we're going to start doing
the exercises which okay might be more
me showing you things than
you typing if most of you don't have a
working mpi but um nevertheless
so parallel community well what is
parallel computing well serial computing
is you know doing things at one time so
it's like one person doing something and
um i hope i'm not gonna get in trouble
for saying it's like a man doing it a
man who can only do one thing at a time
rather than a woman who can multitask um
but it's doing one thing after the other
there's just one stream of execution one
stream of stuff happening we know this
this is how we normally think now modern
computers aren't like that anyway you
know the the screen's updating at the
same time
but
but uh and there are multiple chips in
in your future even ignoring the cpus
but conceptually that's what what the
classical conception of serial computing
is and parallel computing is doing
several things at the same time
literally having different streams of
execution going on
and in particular to call it parallel
computing we normally mean that
those different processors those
different bits of execution are
contributing towards the same task so
it's like breaking a problem down having
a team of people you know digging a hole
or erecting the building rather than a
single person building the building
rather than just lots of people all
doing their own thing it's a coordinated
activity towards an end
there are other things related to
parallel computing like clustered
computing which is where you have a
bunch of machines each of which may be
parallel
or which may be serial which connected
together maybe by a local area network
or a network in which you might throw
jobs at but that's that's different from
parallel computing basically because
it's not tightly enough coupled there's
also the thing that really confuses
people is concurrency
concurrency is not in general
parallelism concurrency is the idea of
several things being done over the same
time period but not but only one of them
being done at the time so it's like if
you have four tasks it's like you do a
bit of task one and then you get paused
and then you do a bit of task two and
then you get pause and then you do a
task three and then you get paused and
this is how time-sharing systems have
worked forever we've had before we had
parallel
um you know uh mainframes and things we
had we had serial mainframes that had a
supervisor script that or supervisor
process
that said right user one can have a bit
of time now and then we're gonna kick
that user one out and we're gonna run
use the two spacer so concurrency is not
parallelism concurrency is about
breaking up a problem so that different
bits can run
um
sort of independently but not
necessarily at the same time and in
general with concurrency not at the same
time so you can have concurrency on a
single serial processor you think about
time sharing you think about interrupts
you think about threads and stuff like
that
there are a bunch of different parallel
computing architectures that we'll talk
through briefly
more briefly than i originally intended
because i produced too much stuff
um so we talked about sisd simd vector
processing and mimd and i'll go through
those so sisd that's we only talk about
sisd because it helps to explain the
parallel stuff so sim sd single
instruction single data that's normal
serial sequential execution
for example testing primes using an
ordinary python program like this that
we don't need to go through because you
all know how to test primes and you'll
know how serial computing
works
and so that's finding
finding whether 29 is prime which it
turns out it is
um so the point about talking about sisd
is that there's also simd so simd single
instruction multiple data which and the
the examples of of these that you'll
know best are gpus gpus are simd systems
and the idea with sam and and i'm from
edinburgh i was actually one of the
first people employed at the in fact the
first person employed at the edinburgh
parallel computing center in 1990
and in edinburgh the first parallel
machines we had were icl daps
distributed array processors and we
eventually had the sexiest computer that
was ever built the thinking machines
connection machine 200 which had 65 536
bit serial processors so one bit
processors
and gpus are like this today except they
use whole words not uh not just single
bits and and the reason and so the idea
with smd is you have a single program
executing you have a single
pro instruction pointer so every process
or every processor is doing exactly the
same step at the same time
but you have lots of simple processes
that all execute that program in
lockstep with each other so think about
an image and some image processing task
where you need to apply a filter and you
only need maybe the pixel and maybe it's
immediate neighbors or it's you know
second degree neighbors or whatever and
and you can just run over the image and
if you've got 10 000 processors you can
do 10 000 pixels at a time you've got
100 000 processors you can do a hundred
thousand plus and these days you might
have a lot more than that so that's simd
that um all branches execute on the same
data it means you can't exit early from
loops and so on so if you find if you if
you imagine doing this to test primality
if you find that a numbers prime it
doesn't mean you can stop because you
still haven't found whether all the
other numbers are prime yet so you can't
exit early you can't take different
branches on different things you can you
can have a mask that says where this is
true do this but it's not it's you know
it's not literally only doing one of the
things so this is ideal for things like
graphics it's ideal for lots of physical
simulations because physics is local and
so if you can kind of chop up a problems
you know space-time or
or an aircraft wing or something into
bits that can work well on an simd
computer
but it's relatively inflexible so i have
got little animations here that show you
know a whole load of inputs and you know
suppose we're randomly multiplying them
by two they all get multiplied by two
and then we're adding three to them this
program is not doing anything useful but
you know then we add three to them all
and then we oops then we go backwards
because i'm not very good with computers
um don't worry about that um
and then maybe we have the equivalent of
an if statement where we say you know
where where the numbers bigger than 10
negate it otherwise double it or
whatever and that probably actually
happens in two separate steps but the
point is you can have ifs it's just that
you kind of execute both branches uh
everywhere and but only apply the result
and then you cube it and then you
produce all your outputs at the same
time or whatever right and so this
example here was an example of one two
three four five six one two three four
five eight way parallelism but you know
think 65 536 or or a million or or like
crazy large numbers of things going on
on gpus
um
okay and i've got an example of doing
the prime testing here again but because
you know you can read it through in your
leisure if you like but you can imagine
the point is all those bits where you
say let's exit early they don't work
testing primality on an simd machine
okay vector processing
vector processing um again maybe the
second sexiest
maybe maybe sexiness isn't the right
thing for computers but anyway this was
a cray xmp which was um one of the there
was actually a ymp after it that was
even better but there were these amazing
looking computers that um were vex
process they were the fastest computers
in the world at the time
and again you have a single process
but you have multiple execution units
and you have a pipeline and the idea is
different bits of the pipeline do i mean
they might do the same operation but in
general different bits of the pipeline
do different bits of the opera you think
of it like a conveyor belt and what
happens is you kind of fill up this
conveyor belt and to start with the
conveyor belt's empty and so at the
first cycle you only process the first
bit of data doing the first operation
but at the next unit so so you start off
with a sort of queue of inputs like this
and then if we're doing the same stupid
operation we had here at each clock
cycle everything kind of moves left at
the top and so then you multiply the
first one by two and it produces two but
now three's moved into that input area
and so the next cycle the two moves down
and gets a three added to it but the
three moves down and gets doubled so we
end up with a six and a five so now
we're doing two things at the second
step and now the seven can move in and
at the next step we'll be able to do
three things because the five can get uh
doubled and the you know
six can get three added to it and seven
can get multiplied by two which is a lot
like doubling isn't it but anyway um you
know and things move down the pipeline
and eventually when you filled up the
pipeline now you're doing four things at
a time and this this pipeline might be a
lot longer than four
um so if you've got you know you might
have a hundred element pipeline or
something and now you've got 100
parallelism but but but different things
are at different steps and then you
start producing outputs and the outputs
this is this is vector processing and at
one point this was the fastest kind of
computing there was
okay but what we're going to be
concentrating on today
15 minutes not terrible
is mimd multiple instruction multiple
data which is of course the most
flexible thing so multiple instructions
again it's all very edinburgh focused
um
the so this was the first mimd computer
we had in admiral which was a maker
computing surface
which was a 40 processor machine it had
40 transputers in it and then it
gradually grew to about 320 and now the
the pcc has a machine with three
quarters of a million full processors in
it which i really struggle to get my
head around
and so now you have um
potentially different pro you have a
bunch of processors they're all kind of
independent though they can talk to each
other and you're running potentially
different programs on each processor now
in fact most of the time you run the
same program program on every processor
so called single press program multiple
data but but they all have their own
instruction points so they can be doing
completely different parts of that
program and indeed you kind of force
stuff into this spmd for convenience
model but often there are different
functions the different processors doing
but still the general idea is you've
just got a bunch of processors all doing
their own thing but cooperating solver
solver problem
and so
with mimd you can exit early because you
can just you know you've just got an
ordinary computer
okay so that's the basic idea of mmd
it's just a whole bunch of different
computers together and you know i don't
know what laptops we have in the room
but i would be surprised if we have any
laptop in the room that doesn't have
more than one core more than one cpu if
you like
in it
maybe maybe there's a really old one
that doesn't but it's unlikely so there
are two different within mimd
there are two different architectures
two different main architectures
so-called shared memory and distributed
memory and again every computer in this
room is probably a shared memory
computer but perversely we're going to
use a distributed memory programming
model for reasons that
if i do a good job will become clear so
what shared memory well shared memory is
what it sounds like if you have
i can move right because
i can move um
i i mean you can still hear me if i move
i can definitely move um so if you have
four processors then you have just one
big block of memory and all the
processors can talk to that memory right
and they this and none of these none of
my architecture diagrams are real
architecture diagrams these are
conceptual programmers ideas of what's
going on don't worry about what's
actually going on in the hardware but
they all maybe they will go through a
memory control or maybe they all have
their own memory controller or whatever
but the point is all of them can read
and write from any bit of that memory
and all of the bits of that memory are
just as fast as any other bits for
reading and writing and so it's dead
simple and
what people like about this is it's
conceptually very simple you've just got
a whole lot of processes a big bunch of
memory anyone can read or write anything
so that's fantastic the only con is that
you have to orchestrate that so you get
contention when different processors are
trying to write the same bit of memory
at the same time you get out of all the
things what if someone's just written
the thing overwritten the thing that you
were trying to read how does all that
work
and so to solve that you have to worry
about locks and things like that
but the really big problem we've shared
with writing to shared primary
shared memory programming models is that
they only work on shared memory systems
and that's fine if you're only ever
going to run them on shared memory
systems but the biggest systems and the
most flexible and most powerful systems
are distributed memory
and the reverse isn't true if you write
for distributed memory systems you can
run them on shared memory systems which
is why i think mpi is an interesting
thing for us to look at
so
um oh so this is this is also known as
symmetric multiprocessing and the
symmetry is about the fact that all the
bits of memory are the same speed for
all the processors
there's another variant of this
called
non-uniform memory architecture
where
the processors come in blocks and
there's a you know the block on the
right is exactly like the thing we just
looked at it's four processors talking
you know with a memory box that they can
use to talk to the memory and the same
on the left
but the processors on the left can't get
quickly to the memory on the right they
can get there but they have to go
through another interconnect through the
processes or through something and it's
slower and so it's non-uniform because
this memory is fast for these four
processes this memory is fast for these
four processors but this memory is slow
for these four processors and and vice
versa
and numa has never i mean there have
been humor machines and they're fine but
they're always a bit unpopular with
programmers because they kind of have
they kind of have the disadvantages of
both systems because um they you know
they have the disadvantage that they're
non-uniform um
so so you have to worry about where
things are
um
the disadvantages of both systems what's
the other disadvantage anyway no one
really likes numa but but but they do
exist
unlovely children um
there's a relationship between this and
clustered and distributed computing
basically if that interconnect is not
like a tight interconnect in a single
box but it's a local area network that's
really what computing cluster is
typically
and if that interconnect is really the
internet then that's really what grid
computing is and you can still solve
problems across it you know all the all
the loosely connected things like you're
probably familiar with the seti at home
screen saver where people gave up spare
cycles on their systems to
uh look for extraterrestrials or there
were there were various i think the some
of the medical people got involved in
that and we looked for cancer and stuff
like that
or maybe it was gene sequencing
something like that anyway
um okay but where it's really at even
though physically this isn't where it's
really at but what we're going to talk
about the programming model we're going
to talk about is for distributed memory
and with distributed memory it it's it's
i don't know if it's what it sounds like
or not but every processor has its own
memory and that memory is private to
that processor
and so process one has its memory one
process two has its memory too and all
the rest of it but they can all talk to
each other through a messaging system
and so you just have to arrange your
computation in such a way that you do
most of your computation on your local
stuff and when you need stuff from
someone else you pass messages to get
access to that so either you ask someone
else to send you some stuff or they just
proactively send you some stuff because
they know they know what you're going to
need
um so the pros of this are that there's
no contention to worry about because
only you have access to your stuff
you can use this is very important you
can use this pro if you program for
distributed memory you can run this on a
shared memory system and all that
happens is you partition up the shared
memory and say well actually we're going
to treat this as if it's your private
memory and then message passing just
becomes copying in local memory so it's
actually even faster it's in some sense
better on a shared memory system than on
distributed memory system because it's
typically
lower latency
and it's very scalable you can build
much bigger distributed memory systems
than you can shared memory systems these
are sometimes called shared nothing
systems which is
complete nonsense because you can see
from the diagram they share stuff but
they
anyway whatever um
cons well arguably it's conceptually
harder
i don't know that i buy that but people
seem to find it conceptually harder it
does involve
message passing which involves copying
and some latency
and there is potential for deadlock and
if you do ever install mpi and try
writing programs in the system you will
you will definitely experience deadlock
um
though i did have a surprise when i was
preparing this when i wrote a program
that i thought was guaranteed to
deadlock and the bloody thing didn't
but anyway we'll come to that so what's
mpi finally nearly finally
what am i doing
that's not bad um
mpi is the message passing interface it
is a high performance general purpose
message passing interface it's extremely
mature um the proposal for mpi for the
first version of mpi was 1991 and it was
implemented basically in 1991 and it
built on other stuff that's even older
than that
i think it's true last time i checked it
was certainly true but i think it's
still true that the vast majority
on any sensible way of counting the vast
majority of large-scale scientific
parallel computing uses mpi it's it's
it's almost all of it at scale the
really big stuff
it is perfect for distributed memory
parallel computing but it's remarkably
good on shared memory systems as well
whereas i say message passing just
becomes local buffer copying
so i think there's a big advantage in
writing using mpi even if you're going
to run on a shared memory system which
let's
face it most of us are most of the time
there are two main implementations
openmpi and mpich
and they're the same uh i couldn't even
tell you which is better than the other
they they both work they're both
fantastic um
i suspect you'd struggle to know which
one i think one of them slightly more
standards compliant and someone's one
slightly faster but they're they're both
great
okay
do we have time for a historical
intellect we'll do a very brief
historical inclu it's really just me
indulging myself but given that you
haven't actually installed mpi
we've got time anyway um so back when i
started at edinburgh doing a phd in
physics and we had these funny parallel
computers
we got as i said this mako computing
surface and they were built out of
transport now transputers were whole
systems on a chip systems on a chip we
talked about that today there were these
little packages that had a processor and
a bit of memory and four communications
links and you could bolt them together
almost like lego you actually typically
got a board which had four of them and
some of the links were set but they you
know there were sort of eight links
pointing out the board and you could you
could reconfigure them in software but
the point is each processor only talk to
four other processors directly and you
know in particular in this particular
wiring diagram processor one isn't
connected to processor six directly so
if it wants to talk to processor six it
has to go via some other set of
processes to find a path that works
um
and so what happened in the beginning
was people actually you know wrote
complicated programs that figured out
how to route their messages to where
they needed to get to and all the rest
of it and tried desperately to arrange
things so that the topology of the
computing grid matched the topology or
problem so you only ever had to talk to
your neighbors which is by far the most
efficient thing anyway
but a rather brilliant guy called mike
norman said
ah this is all too hard i should just
work really hard and write a program
that puts a post office on every
transputer and then when you want to
send a message we'll just give every
processor an address and you just say i
want to send a message to processor
three and the processors will the post
offices will all talk to each other and
make it happen
okay and um
that was called titch the topology
independent transputer communications
harness
and it was fantastic it was incredibly
slow it required seven buffers on every
machine to work
but it was an amazing proof of concept
and so then lyndon clark came along and
um
titch begat tiny so titch was written in
ockham
which was uh this weirdo intrinsically
parallel language um
based on tony hall's communicating
sequential processes model of parallel
computing
um
tiny was exactly like titch except it
was written in c instead of occum and it
was fast and i think it only used two
buffers so that was titubagat tiny
and then in 1990 we formed the edmond
parallel computing center and tiny big
chimp the common high-level interface to
message passing you can see a lot of
work was put into these these names
um
[Music]
chimp was also written in c but it had
bindings for fortran and that was
incredibly important because although
everyone in this room thinks fortran
like died about 100 years ago
actually 4chan is still the most common
use
most common language in scientific
computing and a huge amount of work that
epcc did used fortran so that was that
was super important
and then in 1991 chimp was one of the
inputs to mpi the message passing
interface which was which became an
international standard and which is the
mpi that we still used today right the
way back in 1991
now from an edinburgh point of view i'm
i'm not this is this is not a neutral
presentation of how mpi developed but if
you if you were in edinburgh like me and
the only people you knew were the people
who wrote titch and tiny and chimp uh as
far as i can tell there was titch and
tiny and chimp and then it got renamed
mpi and that's what we used today
apparently these jack don garron tony
hay and all these other places they had
ideas too and they all probably
contributed lots to mpi and i'm i'm
absolutely certain they did but i don't
know what those bits were as far as i'm
concerned it looked like that so end of
historical interview edinburgh is great
you should come there it's really
beautiful and it's not as hot as here
okay
um
half an hour that's that's pretty good
we're going to have time for you all to
do hands-on stuff using the code you
haven't installed
um
okay before we
that probably is actually not about are
there any questions at this point before
we actually start looking at how you
program with mpi and all that kind of
stuff
it's okay am i going too slowly or too
fast or
i can't i mean i can't really go back
and change it but i could change the
next bit
i do the next bit in parallel or
something
have we got another screen
okay no questions well that's that's
that's either good or bad
or
neutral i guess
um
okay so
the main way if you read the mpi
documents in particular if you read the
mpi for so sorry
mpi for python so as i say there are two
main implementations of mpi and they
both have bindings for essentially every
computer language that that matters and
that's not me being dismissive of
computer language i mean they have i
don't know how many languages they have
bindings for but it would be like 30 or
50 or 100 or so it's absolutely huge
numbers you can basically use mpi with
any reasonable programming language you
might want to
you might want to use it with
um
the python bindings for mpi um the main
version is called mpi for pi which is
maintained by this egyptian guy whose
name i have forgotten but is on the
slides later
lissandria or something i think
and the standard way of running an mpi
program in python is not to run python
directly but is to use a program that
gets installed when you pip install mpi
for pi which you can only do after
you've installed mpi
uh to use this mpi wrapper which
basically you say mpi exec
saying i want to execute something using
mpi you tell it the number of processors
that you want to use which is typically
the number of processors on your system
and it should be the number of hardware
processes not any virtual processors
so four would be a good answer for a lot
of people in the room a few of you might
have eight process machines some of you
might have two
uh and then you give it the command you
want to run which is in this case python
food opera if python if food.pi is a
program that uses mpi for pi
and therefore mpi
so for example when i run
uh mirrors tests which is one of the
things that i regularly mirror is the
software package that i do most of my
work in when i run it sets i have a
script called p-test and this is what i
run
um there is a thing i tend to run on
macs and and um it sometimes doesn't
exit cleanly because of some bug
somewhere if you don't set this variable
omp imc btl to self comma tcp i have no
idea what any of that means but it stops
the errors happening so it makes me
happy i actually have that set in my dot
bash rc as well
and then i time it then i run mpi exec
minus n and then this cis control
c ctl minus n
hw dot physical cpu tells you how many
cores there are in your system on a
linux or
macintosh system i don't know if there's
any windows in the room i don't know how
you find out programmatically how many
processors are on a windows machine but
i'm sure there's a similar way of doing
it
and so this says so on the laptop i've
got here this returns eight and so it
will run eight way parallel like that
and then python three or python or
whatever this can be whatever the path
to your executable python is it just
doesn't have to be anything in
particular um
i do tend to say minus mmpi for pi but
you don't need that actually and then p
test which is p test dot pi which is my
parallel test script and then whatever
else i put on the command line gets
passed
straight through
so that's in general how you run an mpi
program
it is possible
and in fact i prefer
to just run a python program and then to
spawn the processes from within python
dynamically
but we probably won't really get to that
today
but it's important to know that that's
that's an option too and if you did want
if i'm sure there's no one in the room
who does this but if any of you for
example i don't know spend an unhealthy
amount of your life in jupiter you might
find running it with mpi exec
inconvenient and you might prefer
running it directly from python using
dynamic process creation
so that's the thing
okay
mpi let's look at the simplest mpi
program
uh this is a simple mpi program so we'll
go through all of it so the command at
the top is how you run it obviously it
says minus n2 but it's minus n however
many processors you've got or well no in
this case in this case you really do
want to run it with two actually
so we import mpi for pi or rather we
import the mpi object from mpi for pi
uh which is just a global that we have
and then we create or rather we get
access to a communicator which is
actually an intercom in mpi speak
as mpi.comworld so this is the thing
that we use to talk to other process we
can talk to any other process or
processor in the system using this
communicator
and we do a get rank and get the rank of
a process in mpi is just your your
processor number so if you run with four
processors there will be a process zero
process one process two and process
three they always start from zero
they're always contiguous that's
guaranteed it's not assuming anything
that's just how mpi
works
and so in this case what we're then
going to do is a switch that says
if my rank is zero then i'm going to
send a message and if my rank is one i'm
going to receive a message so this
process is just going to send a message
from process zero or process or zero to
process one
i'm not really going to sink in
processes and processors in mpi you
almost always want exactly one process
per process or certainly for any simple
use that's what you want
so
so on on the xero process we just
construct a message it's just a string
it can be any pickleable python python
object if you don't know what pickling
is we might talk about that later
but any any regular python object is
going to be fine
and then we say com.send
so we use the intercom to send this
message we tell it what we want to send
the thing we want to send is our message
which in this case the string but even
though i've called it message it doesn't
have to be a string it could be an array
of numbers it could be an object it
could be a fairly complex thing it's
going to be a dictionary for example
and we tell it where it's going to go to
and so we want to send it to one because
well i'm zero and i want to send it to
one and we've only got two processors so
that's the other one and so that's all
that happens on processor one except it
it tells us what we've done
and then uh we say uh otherwise if rank
is one which is the only other
possibility we do arrest a receive
and we wait for a message
and we can tell it where we want to get
it from match we don't need to tell it
where we get it from if we don't put in
that source equals zero it will just
accept a message from anywhere so we can
use this to determine if several
messages are coming in which one to get
but that's that's what's going on
uh and then we print something there and
when i run this this is what happens but
given that you have no so well if oh no
i'll say a couple of other things this
stuff on the side so both intercom.send
and what i've written as
intercom.receive but should be
intercom dot recv sorry about that
it's amazing how much more visible
mistakes are
when they're on a big screen then
these are blocking operations
what does blocking mean blocking means
that it actually doesn't mean what you
think it means even who knew what do you
think blocking means
until it's finished okay anyone else
yeah that's what you think it means
wouldn't you that's what the name
suggests that's not what it means
it almost means that but it means
something subtly different from that
just to you know really confuse you
it blocks until
it's safe for you to overwrite the data
that you're sending
it does not necessarily block until the
message has been sent so when it comes
back it doesn't mean the message has
been sent
you will think it means the message has
been sent you will often act as if it
means the message has been sent but it
doesn't actually mean that it just means
it's safe for you to overwrite whatever
you're doing so if you've got some
mutable array that you're passing you
can mutate it further and and that's
fine
that's what the blocking is about so it
does block it blocks for a period of
time potentially but it decides whether
or not it's going to take a copy of the
thing and then give you back control and
send it later or whether it's actually
going to wait until it's finished
sending it and the general rule of thumb
is if it's a small thing that you give
it then it will copy it and hand back
control almost immediately but if it's a
big thing
it will um
because it it hasn't got it hasn't got
too much buffer space to spare um it
will wait until it's actually centered
so you don't know and that's that's one
of the places everyone gets tripped up
in in mpi
uh the receive is a blocking receive as
well and that does mean that it blocks
until the message until the variable's
actually been filled in
so if you
so now that we're now that we're a bit
later who's got are working
oh wow wow wow that is worth that is
absolutely worth pausing on um
well those of you who are we will pause
but those of you who already have it uh
working if you've cloned the thing you
could just run the script or you could
type it typing is really good for you
even if you don't type it now go home
and type it afterwards i know it sounds
stupid i know it sounds like a waste of
time
your fingers learn things your brain
learns things by doing not just by git
cloning
i will run it and then we will have a
little interlude where we all try and
install it with conda
those of us who've got conda installed
so i have a terminal here am i in the
right place
i'm in the right place so if i say
if i say this
and it tells us that processor xero sent
the message dear one high love zero and
processor one received a message from
zero
dear one hi love zero
which is about as fantastic as
things get
not that i want to downplay expectations
for the session but
so that's a basic blocking send and
receive
my friend
what's your name
juan luis juan luis juan luis would you
like to could you could could you give
juan luis the microphone
could you tell people the magic
incantation to get everything working
without compiling mpi from source the
mpi for pi is
mpi 4pi is basically compiled already as
a condo package so if you do conda
install mpi for pi
minus minus channel conda forge
it works you don't need to compile mpc
or anything like that i can i can help
so
say it again conda
install
minus minus
like that
yes
okay i'm not going to do that
because i have a working mpi for pi and
i'd quite like to keep it that way
not that i'm sure anything would go
wrong but if you don't have a working
con if you don't have a working mpi for
pi you might want to try that
i'll leave that there just for a couple
of minutes we're making such brilliant
progress
um we can we can afford to
we can afford to take five minutes and
let people try and install it
i could tell jokes what no maybe not
yeah the one about how dominic rabb
thinks it's not clear why the ethics
advisor resigned
i mean how embarrassed is supposed to be
able to read
oh no if i do that that's not gonna help
is it yes con that's that's very simple
isn't it condor installed mpi for five
minus spanish channel conda dash forge
yes
is juan luis wrong does it not work
[Music]
try it but nothing would happen it would
be exactly the same it does there's
there's no difference between zero and
one they're entirely equivalent
it's just the message would go the other
way
but you don't know which one's zero
which one one's anywhere so it's kind of
so it'd be fine you can try it you can
that's a good change to make so the
question was
the question was
what would happen
if
i'm going to try and leave it
so that's still visible what would
happen if we swapped zero and one in
this program the answer
the answer is nothing or other you
wouldn't detect any difference at all
well would you you would detect a
difference which is that it would now be
lying when it said dear one i love zero
because really the message should be
dear zero high love one but other than
that i mean you but it wouldn't change
so actually what would happen was i
suppose that is the change the program
would lie and it would say
that it was the the the it would suggest
that xero had sent a message to one and
that one had received it whereas what
would in fact have happened was one
would have sent a message impersonating
zero to
anyway but no it would work exactly the
same and you should try that if you have
a working mpi for pi try that and
my prediction is the output will be
uh
oh well
oh sorry if you swap that button but you
don't swap those
oh we'll come to that no no that's a
that's a different thing
but but it's but these are not but but
it's not a question of before and after
here
what's happening on processor zero is
it's doing ascend and what's happening
on processor one is it's doing a receive
and and the whole point of parallelism
is they're happening at the same time
on processor zero only this part of the
code executes and on processor one only
this part of the code executes
so it doesn't matter if you
right so another thing is what if you
what if you put the if the other way
around if you put this branch wouldn't
make any difference at all
but yes if you do
well we'll we'll work
you're keen on this deadlock thing if
you if
you try to receive before the send
potentially things well it's it's not
even so much which order you do things
it's
it's
it's really nice in in mpi in fact not
just nice um it's sort of necessary for
things to work that whenever one person
person whenever one process ascends the
other process receives and whenever one
process receives the other one sends
because especially with blocking stuff
otherwise they'll deadlock if you're
non-blocking stuff which we are going to
talk about to
you still really fundamentally need that
but you've got a bit more flexibility
about the order of things which is which
is what we'll see in a moment okay has
everyone at least copied that typed
conda install npi for pi management's
channel con to forge
i'm going to assume you don't have that
installed and working yet
mpi uh
really
what about mpo try mpi run
npr run is exactly the same as mpi exec
except for small differences that
no
but that worked for you
[Laughter]
works on my machine um
it seems to me that the condor and solar
is broken if it doesn't give you mpi
exec because you need that it could be a
path issue obviously
um what so okay so it worked for you it
didn't work for you who else has tried
and
and it worked
yeah yeah it's not looking good at the
moment
um
didn't work with you okay so that's
two-two
we could if i had if i had a i've got a
pen actually but i suspect they're not
gonna like it if i start writing on here
um
okay so two two two works two didn't
work any any advance on
worked i also tried
you can tell emilyn's a pie data
organizer he thinks of things like that
trying trying random [ __ ] and sorry
random stuff and
good
oh okay um
i am not qualified and we don't have
time to try and diagnose what's going
wrong but at least we have more now we
could we could start doing the thing
where people gather around the screen
and see if it works for other people and
stuff okay that was the simplest one
what how are we doing what we've got to
we've got we've got quarter past four
okay
so this is kind of what we're talking
about so the way you conceptualize this
is probably and the way almost everyone
conceptualize this this is that you do
the send and what what happens in the in
a blocking send is that it waits for
process one to initiate the receive and
then sends the message and then returns
control and then it does the print right
on processor zero and on processor one
it waits presses siri to initiate the
send and then it receives the message
then it returns control to the calling
program and does the print and that
might happen that does happen some other
time if the message was big that
probably is what would happen
but
um
as i say the call blocks until it's safe
for you to overwrite the data not until
the operation is completed
and it is quite important to bear that
in mind
it may copy your object and then return
control for you uh or it may wait until
it's been sent and you actually there is
a way to influence it but
again that's that's like a more advanced
topic that we're not going to worry
about
but you shouldn't need to know it's the
point what matters is whether you can
mutate the data because
you're not you're not really going to do
anything with with your knowledge about
what the other process is doing with
blocking receives
the call blocks until it's till it's
complete and when you regain control
you're guaranteed that the transfer is
complete
so you do pretty much know that return
has been controlled to the sending
processes where you don't absolutely
know but it seems very likely
okay but here's another possible
timeline therefore
so what could happen is that you do the
send mpi copies the message it returns
control to you it prints that it sent
the message then it waits for process
one to initiate the receive then it
sends the message
and that's completely valid as well and
it will
it won't look any different for you as
long as you write a correct program
there's another minor variant but it's
it's not really very different so it
doesn't matter
um so
in general all right so in general
so this is how blocking works and it's
it's
it's often easiest to start off doing
blocking communications you can normally
write a version of the program that
works with blocking communications but
the problem with blocking is it
introduces idle time i either computer
weights around blocking not doing
anything useful on that
process and that's detrimental to
performance
but it does make the code easier to
reason about
the downside of blocking apart from
performance is that it creates the
conditions for deadlock which is i think
what you were worrying about what
happens if
you do a send and no one receives
and you often need to use and it's often
so it's often a good idea to use some
non-blocking communications
um to
both to reduce idle time
and to
um avoid deadlock
and it's important to realize that
you can do a blocking send with a
non-blocking receive and you can do a
non-blocking
long blocking send with a blocking
receive or you can mix them however you
like yes sorry there's a hand
okay so the question was does deadlock
occur because of a bug in your program
or because it gets lost
so on correctly functioning hardware and
correctly implemented mpi libraries and
mpi for pi
um it's always because of a bug in your
program and in practice it's almost
always because of a bug in your program
one of the super frustrating things
about
parallel programming in general
is that you can write code that works
and you can run the tests a thousand
times you can run it on all sorts of
different systems and it's fine and then
suddenly it doesn't work and quite
possibly it never works again that's
certainly how it feels
and all that's happened is your your
code was always wrong but you were lucky
the first you know 999 times you ran it
or something
and
um this is one of those moments when i
have to say so i don't work at epcc
anymore i did work at epcc that was like
25
no it's probably more than two anyway it
was a lot of years ago um and uh i was
slightly nervous that i might have
forgotten some things about parallel
competing which i definitely had so i
did take the code that uh we're working
on today in and get someone at epcc to
verify now that doesn't mean that if
there's a bug in it it's his fault
obviously it's completely my fault that
i wrote buggy code but just to reassure
you even if i have forgotten everything
i knew 30 years ago
someone else thinks this code might
actually be sound
you know
but yes okay so now let's create
deadlock
so
here's a program here's another program
that we're going to run with mpi exec
equals two uh sorry with with with two
processors exactly um so we're going to
get my rank so we're going to run the
same code there's no ifs in this uh i'm
going to get my rank and i'm going to
call that me and i'm going to therefore
deduce that the other processor's rank
is one minus me because if i'm zero
that'll be one and if i'm one that'll be
zero
and then i'm going to create a message
dear other high love me and then i'm
going to send that message and then i'm
going to receive a message from the
other one and then i'm going to print
them both
and it should be entirely obvious to
everyone
that this is a deadlocking program
because we both do ascend and we block
and then we both do a receive but we'll
never get to the receive because
we're blocked right
so
um
yeah it's difficult if most of you
haven't actually got working
implementation so i uh
i wonder if i should run it
um
well what i was going to say at this
point and i suppose i will still say is
you should copy your first program
because this is encouraging the typing
thing and modify it it's quite similar
to this modify it to look like this and
then
run it as long as you know how to kill
processes on your system because if you
don't know how to kill processes you
might end up with a system that's that's
a bit
i mean you could restart it but um you
can just use control c or control z or
whatever on unix and linux
and kill the processes yep
gold star
that's exactly right i wrote this
program fully expecting it would fail
and it didn't fail
it worked and the reason it works is
because these messages are small and it
does in fact copy well at least on my
system it copies them and therefore it
doesn't block so i will run it
if you are
i really haven't thought this through
however if i run that you're not gonna
be able to see the code anymore
um
but you've got a copy of the code
locally anyway i don't know most of you
haven't got working things so if i run
that um
because i
have deadlock risk and you might have
noticed it's called risk if i run that
with this command
then what actually happens is it works
fine
i shouldn't have said that before i'd
run it it might work fine and in fact it
did work fine and the reason it worked
fine is exactly sorry what's your name
thomas and it's exactly for the reason
thomas said and that we started talking
about which is that although this is
obviously a an unsound program in fact i
would say this is a buggy program you
would certainly expect this program to
fail a lot of the time you certainly
would never rely on this program working
because it has no right to work
actually it will work because that
message is short enough that almost all
mpi implementations will copy it return
control so they'll both do the send
they'll come back and then they'll do
the receipts and then that will allow
the sends actually to happen
and then it will finish
um
so we haven't actually succeeded in
creating deadlock
even though it turns out deadlock's
really easy to create and you will if
you if you do anything with mpi you will
definitely succeed in creating deadlock
but just not not quite this
this easily now that was slightly subtle
even though thomas worked it out would
it be helpful to anyone if i went
through that again
yes
and what
one hand going up means is that probably
half the people in the room would
benefit from it so we'll do it again
so
what you think is happening just from
kind of the language is that you think
this is sending a message or
constructing a message sending the
message waiting until that message has
been sent and because both processors
trying to send it obviously can't work
but it does work because mpi has freedom
when you do a blocking send to copy the
message that you're sending
into a local buffer and then to return
control to you and only to send it when
it's able to do that so what actually
happens is because this is small
it actually does copy the message so it
you do the comm dot send it copies your
message to a buffer it hands control
back to you then it does the receive and
that's happening on both processors and
so now they're both waiting for a
receive a blocking receive but that
blocking receive can happen because the
other end there's ascend ready to go now
and mpi uses interrupts to take back
control and all the rest of it and sends
the messages so it does work
well it might not work but it works for
me emily does it not work for you
have you been reading ahead
um good uh gold star for emilyn as well
um
so oh good lord there's a slide about
this we've talked about this anyway it's
19 characters it's it's about 75
characters including all pythons
overhead when you pickle it it gets very
slightly bigger but it doesn't really
make any difference so let's force
deadlock
emilyn's already done it by forcing it
to be bigger did you do it by doubling
the message size each time till it
failed
well there you go so here's a here's a
i'm not gonna say it's more scientific
than that but here's a
here's a way of diagnosing it further so
what we're gonna do is almost exactly
what emilyn did
um
we're going to
uh keep multiplying our string we're
going to multiply not a but that but our
whole message
so we're going to do a string of length
19 and we're going to multiply that by 2
to the n for different values of n going
up through a loop and see what happens
so it's essentially same code so again
in in my enthusiasm for getting you to
type things because typing is really
good for the soul unless you've got rsi
it's still good for the soul if you've
got rsi it's just less good for your
fingers um
but um
is to copy the previous program and put
a loop in and and do all this stuff but
again because not absolutely everyone
has
got that
have you already implemented a task farm
yet emily
have you already implemented the task
farm as well
no okay i i just thought you seemed to i
mean
just seem to be on the golden path um
so i will show you what happens if i run
this program you notice i'm not taking
my advice and typing it but i have typed
all this code
um well with a bit of help from copy and
paste obviously
um
so
deadlock two deadlock what happens if i
run to deadlock
how does it say to run to deadlock
it's uh you can see i'm so keen on
typing i'm not gonna risk typing the
command
so
ah
um
so what happens is
things don't necessarily come out in the
right order in parallel processing
that's another thing because you know
all that contention stuff i was talking
about that's still true for screen
output if you really are stupid enough
to have printing going on from rods
process which is fine during debugging
but not very good in real life
so processor zero sends four messages
you know 19 and a no what
oh no i'm sorry processor zero center
message of 19 it received a 38. it sent
a 90 processor zero cent and nineteen
yeah there you go
oh did it start at two to the zero it
probably started to i knew whatever it
it succeeds with all the little ones but
then as they get bigger
as they get bigger eventually it gets
two so it succeeded in both directions
with 2432
but now it's hanging is dead locking and
my god is it consuming power did
everyone get the bit about bring a power
adapter because one of the things
these machines are very highly optimized
to use almost no power at all and then
we run mpi on them and they run all the
cores all the time maximum speed and
then they deadlock and even though you
might think it's not doing very much
work deadlock takes a lot of work so at
this point you either type control c
which might work
or might not work yeah it worked here um
and if that doesn't work you normally
type control z and then you've got stop
jobs and so you do kill percent or
whatever and that kills your job so it
looks like uh so that's a message of
length
2432
and
um and it's a 19 character message and
there's a little bit of overhead for the
string
so that's probably saying that it broke
about 32k in fact there's a very good
chance that it broke exactly 32k because
that's probably what mpi uses mpi for pi
uses as the maximum battery size it
copies
um has anyone else i know emilyn's run
it with a
an a variant a
variant of this
um has anyone else succeeded in running
that and cnet hang
okay
so that's the deadlocking that's the
deadlocking version
oh my god
okay okay yes no no no that's fine
because it's only doing a copy um
yeah so it should be fast
okay uh so we've succeeded in creating
it's it's it's a bit sad that the first
thing i try and teach you to do is to
create deadlock but the point is you
need to know how to avoid these things
there was a hand
yeah
um
experience suggests that they are not
idle and that they're in kind of a spin
loop and that they're working pretty
hard and can't do any other stuff
we could
but why don't we do a scientific
experiment and find out what happens on
a mac
by
running activity monitor
and seeing what happens if we run that
program again
you could do this yourself
so both cores are running at 99. some
101.1 of one cpu that's this
this machine is so parallel it's
incredible it can
um yeah that looks like it's pretty busy
to me
um
so yeah it you probably don't really i
mean actually really deadlock it i mean
i know i know it was fun to create it
but you know it's
it's like the bit where you you cut
yourself a bit and then learn that if
you pushed a bit harder your whole thumb
would come off and you you don't want to
do that anymore um so it's why you
why your dad told you you should whittle
sticks or maybe your mum told you you
should whittle sticks
yeah i think they're in a busy loop yeah
actively trying to do stuff yeah
um
so yes
which is why one of the important
prerequisites for this thing was to
bring a power cable because you will be
you will be desecrating the planet
during this session
um okay were there any other questions
or
okay uh now it obviously might be
different on your machine different
different systems might have different
buffer sites and in particular different
mpis might have different buffer sizes
and all the rest of it but i think i
think mpi5 uses a 32k cutoff for that
buffer okay let's talk about
non-blocking communications
so there are non-blocking counterparts
to
intercom which should have a capital i
sorry we'll just fix it while we're here
because
because then it'll be better next time
around when you all
come next year and say i didn't
understand it last year
or i didn't have mpi for pie
oh god sake
there you go um
so non so
there are there are non-blocking
counterparts to both send and receive
um
and with non-block with the non-blocking
versions
you initiate a send or you initiate a
receive and what you get back is a
handle
and that handle
you can then wait on at le or you can
either test to see whether it's whether
that operation is completed or you can
wait on it and then it will block until
until it has completed but what that
means is that you can
uh
initiate an unblocking send or receive
do some other stuff and later at a point
where potentially everything's set up
you can come back and wait when you
actually need the result of whatever it
was you were doing
so the non-blocking versions just have
an i in front of them so i send is an
unblocking send and i recf is an
unblocking receive
so the general form of an unblocking
send is you say request equals
com.i send data and wherever you want to
send it to
and then at a later point you do a
wreck.wait and when
that comes back you know that you can
overwrite the buffer and that
everything's completed
well you know that you can overwrite the
buffer i guess more specifically
and in the case of an unblock and
receive you do request equals com.i
receive
potentially do some other stuff and then
if you're not going to do all the stuff
there's no point you might as well just
do a blocking version and then you say
data equals rec.weight
and that will return only when data's
been filled in with the result of that
receive
okay
so
um
oh yes yes this is this is this is
probably my favorite slide a
non-blocking receive can set can receive
a message from a blocking send or an
unblocking send a blocking receive can
receive a message from a non-blocking
send so if you like boston boxes and
everyone likes boston boxes except me i
hate boston this is my favorite ever
boston box this is the compatibility
matrix for blocking and non-blocking
sends and receives
and it's all good
you still get deadlock but that's a
different thing it's perfectly
legitimate to do this and it will work
if you write correct code so write
correct code and you'll be fine
uh note no no no note um
ah yes
yes yes yes
um
so the guy who maintains mpi for pi is
in fact lissandra dalson or maybe it's
dalchin i don't know he's an egyptian
fella
and i didn't understand why things
weren't working
as i was preparing these slides and i
found this comment from the guy who
writes mpi for pi
which might put you off mpi for fights
it's better than this makes it sound
but what he says is the implementation
of irs for large messages requires users
to pass a buffer-like object large
enough to receive the pickled stream
this is not documented as most of mpi
for pi and even non-obvious and
unpythonic but if you have some good
knowledge about mpi you'll understand
its limitations for implementing i
receive for pickled streams
which is not super encouraging but what
that's really telling you is that if you
don't know that your message is going to
be small in particular is going to be
less than 32k that same magic number
you actually have to give mpi for pi
a buffer to receive
into and you do that by creating a byte
array it's always wider it doesn't
matter what kind of data you're sending
this he's suggesting a one megabyte byte
array which is what this creates but you
need to provide it with a buffer and you
just provide that as a first positional
argument
and then everything proceeds the same
way
so
you need to note that and if you don't
know that
you might be sad
um so buffers and pickling um
so send i send
receive and i receive
can work with any picklable python
object what's pickling who knows what
pickling is wrong question everyone
knows what pickling is who doesn't know
what pickling is
is there anyone
excellent there's someone who doesn't
know what pickling is that means half of
you don't know what pickling is
in my experience um
pickling is serialization we have
structures like real structures like not
the type on this slide but like an
actual python structure that is a
dictionary a maps to one be maps to two
or whatever
and those are structured objects and
they can't just be sent down
communication channels communications
channels just accept bytes
so the process of marshaling in general
and serialization in general and in
python pickling is the process of taking
some complex structured object like that
and turning it in some kind of byte
stream doesn't really matter what it is
that can be sent down in channel so
turning it into a a string but not even
just a string not a unicode string an
actual byte string you know bytes object
that's what pickling is and loads of
stuff in python is that most python
structures can be pickled um you mostly
get into trouble if they have uh sort of
mutual references within each other so
you have two things that point to each
other it can be quite difficult to pick
all those but in general most stuff you
can do is picklable and there's a
standard the part of sound library is
a pickle function that is used when you
want to take some data structure and
write it to disk uh and and many of you
will have will have used that and that's
what happens behind the scenes when you
pass python objects using
um
using mpi now there's another
these four methods that we've learned
about so far send receive i send and i
receive there are corresponding versions
that have a capital letter for sending
raw
byte buffers
so things like numpy arrays that are
already in c land and don't have all the
python overhead you can send directly
using the capitalized versions of these
and that's much faster because they
don't need to get pickled
um so that's what that's what's going on
there
we're not going to look very much at
doing stuff with numpy today but
absolutely one of the really major use
cases for mpi and python is to send
um is to send numpy arrays or similar
things or raw byte streams uh it will be
faster and there's no point in
parallelizing slow code so you should be
using numpy or whatever is fast
beforehand so you've probably got those
objects kicking around and you should
definitely use the capitalized versions
of them if you're doing that
so
now
let's uh modify the code
emilyn's probably already done this and
created a buffer that's exactly one
bigger than his
array for probably forgetting the fact
that he's got to add the python overhead
of
26 characters or whatever it is i know
51 characters or whatever it is anyway
probably not forgetting that at all so
here's a version of it that tries to get
round the problem
um
by using
uh non-blocking
sends and non-blocking receives
and because of what we read on bitbucket
from lisandro we're going to create a
buffer we're going to make that buffer
a megabyte which is easily big enough we
could we could figure out how big it
actually needs to be but a megabyte it's
not particularly excessive and so what
we do now is basically the same thing as
before but now we do a non-blocking send
and we collect the request and we call
that our wreck
we're doing we're doing the receive
before the send but we could do it the
other way around it wouldn't matter we
do the send
and then we wait on the receive
and when that's finished we know that
we've actually got the data and we can
print stuff
and then a crucial thing that almost
everyone tries to get away with not
doing but it will make you sad if you
don't do it is
even for sends you do need to call the
weight even if you don't want to
overwrite the buffer otherwise your
program will develop a memory leak and
memory leaks are really bad and you want
to avoid them so
you always want to wait on sends even if
you don't care whether it's been sent or
whether the memory is
available for reuse you need to do it
just as a bookkeeping thing you can do
it later
but you don't want to leave it you don't
just want to like build up all your
sense and do them at the very end of the
program or whatever in if you're doing a
lot of them because
you'll leak memory like crazy if you do
that so this version of the code
the main point isn't the buffering
that's just an implementation detail the
main point the buffering in the sense of
creating the buffer um but because we're
using non-blocking sends and receives
here this is guaranteed not to deadlock
well guaranteed this is a correct
program that should not deadlock
unless of course there's a bug and it's
not a correct problem but i believe this
to be a correct program that won't
deadlock
so those of you which is probably most
of you by now who've got a working mpi
for pi how are we doing for time
all 22 bloody hell
um
i will run this very quickly just to
prove that everything's as i say it is
and then we'll get on to all the really
exciting stuff
20 minutes that's not going to be enough
to do the rest of the stuff
um
that's not how i run this mpi
exact minus and
it's just two isn't it
and it all ran through right up to 622
592 characters um not characters um well
characters are yeah currents in the
string that's right and even more than
that including the python overhead and
it all works fine
um
oh and it's falling off the bottom of
the screen sorry about that
um okay uh by all means carry on doing
that but i think we had better press on
otherwise we'll only have looked at
deadlock and not much else
so that all works that's good i get this
error if i don't pass the buffer
so we've talked about that python
objects need these versions capitalized
objects we'll do byte arrays um as i say
python's slow and and
if you're one of the people who
maintains python isn't slow i know all
the arguments the python isn't slow
python slow um
even though it's got fast libraries you
can write code and all the rest of it so
it makes sense to optimize code before
trying to parallelize it and using numpy
is often part of that
so all the examples i'm showing you
today are stupid but i hope i'm giving
you enough information to
allow you to use it for real on sensible
things um
there's some stuff which i'm not going
to talk about but you you do you you
should generally specify types when
you're sending numpy arrays mpi has a
set of types that you can use there are
examples that are available
so let's talk a little bit about data
parallelism versus functional
parallelism so with functional
parallelism we take code and we allocate
to different processes different
functions and we write kind of separate
programs so maybe ones you know one's a
one's an oboe player and one's a trumpet
player and one's a you know whatever or
think of it how you like
um
and there's often some functional
parallelism in programs but functional
parallelism is hard to scale because you
know maybe you can maybe you can think
of four different functions that it's
useful for your code to do but you
probably can't think of sixty five
thousand five hundred and thirty six
things you probably don't want to write
65 536 separate programs or whatever so
what we mostly do is we use data
parallelism with data parallelism we
have either the same code typically the
same code running on every processor or
just a very small number of rooms and
we're going to talk about task farm
where we have one special program that
acts as a controller or a manager or
whatever and a whole load of workers
that do all the work and and basically
they work on different data is the idea
data parallelism um
so yeah spm with spmd
um you can literally just as as as we
did in some of the examples be running
the same code uh
on every processor without any branching
or you can use branching to say well
we'll run this bit on some of the
process and this bit on other others of
the processes but nevertheless
fundamentally you haven't got very much
functional parallelism
there so let's talk about task form
so it's probably the simplest general
purpose parallel paradigm they occur all
over the place
basic idea is that you have one process
one process or which is given a
collection of tasks to be form and that
in the past that was typically known as
the master but as with other things
we're trying to avoid words like masters
and slaves so we tend to talk about the
controller or the manager or the main or
the distributor or the queen bee or
whatever
but anyway someone the controller who
has the tasks and then a whole bunch of
workers who are there to do things the
manager allocates tasks to each worker
collects results from each worker if
there are results from the worker
sometimes they're just doing something
and writing something to the file system
or whatever but if they are
if there's a result to be returned it
gets returned to the
to the manager typically
and then if there are still tasks left
when you return the result of your task
as a worker you get another task sent to
you and so on and so forth until there
are no tasks left at which point
a well-behaved manager will shut you
down and that will be the end
with a task farm usually the tasks are
completely independent so you might have
to send some data to specify the task
but typically um the the workers don't
then need to talk to each other it's not
impossible for them to need to talk to
each other but in a simple task form
that's not the case so we talk about
embarrassingly parallel problems which
are ones where all the bits of it are
just basically completely independent
and there are lots of lots of problems
like that and they're perfect for task
forms
um so what does task form look like so
if we have ten tasks and we have a
manager and three workers because that
fits on the screen nicely
what happens is the manager sends task
one to worker one probably um
and so worker one does that for a while
and then manager two pretty the manager
almost immediately sends a task to
worker two as well task two
uh and sends task three to
worker three i mean the manager might
decide to allocate them in some funkier
way than that but that's what most
managers do and then at some point the
task completes so task two turned out to
be quite a little to us so these tasks
don't all have to be the same size this
is one of the important things and so a
result gets returned to the manager at
this point we've got a result for task
two so that appears up here and now the
manager being a bit of a slave driver
not that we're going to use the word
slave so the manager being a bit of a
bit keen uh immediately sends another
task task four to work two
uh and so worker two does that and that
turns out to be a pretty quick one as
well
and so now we've got a result four and
so worker two who's really grinding
through the stuff here but doing pretty
simple stuff gets task five and task
five goes on and so forth and we just
carry on like this
and so now we've got result one because
that one's finished and so now uh
whoever was doing work oh no no now also
we get result back from t3 because
there's stuff happening in parallel it's
like at the same time it's
it's amazing um and so now we've got a
result three as well and then eventually
uh the manager gets around sending a
task to tasks to worker three task six
uh which turns out to be quite a big one
and also sends a task task seven to
uh worker one and then task five
finishes and you know all the rest of it
you see the thing carrying on so this is
the general way a task farm works
took me ages this i hope you're all
really enjoying it
um
and i have to remember to stop because
if i go past the up
i go past the end then it's very
difficult to go back but fortunately i
copied the output so we end up we end up
saying this so one of the things that
you see with this is that the whole
thing takes longer than you might want
it to because we happen to allocate task
nine which is quite a big one towards
the end and so actually the only
processor working at the end was
processor one doing task nine
so if you can arrange for it so if you
know how big the tasks are ahead of time
it can help to allocate the big tasks
first so that all those get done early
and we try to avoid this situation but
what you can also see is that the total
length of those lines if you add okay
there are idle times between the tasks
when you're waiting for your next task
and you can do something about that but
what you do see is the total length of
the lines is a lot longer than longer
than the total length of the task here
so in this incredibly um i
basically call this a mathematical proof
task farms can speed things up because
the total length of the lines is more
than the width of the width of the
diagram which more or less proves it
you're going to suggest this isn't an uh
perfect mathematical proof aren't you
uh task four has initiated the send
before task five is sent so i think it's
okay
well that's a good question it is
possible that the the the this animation
wasn't an absolutely perfect
implementation of a taskbar um
it's a good point it's it's it's
possible it's possible that there is
some truth in in what you're saying and
that it wouldn't work quite like this
fortunately my programming is much
better than my um my keynote skills so
um
yeah good point okay so um
[Music]
how much this do we want to do we've got
we've got 11 minutes we're not going to
go through the task form i have i have
printed out in glorious detail a task
form that you can run you have the task
from here that you can use and there's a
stupid little example and there are some
exercises the main thing that i think is
interesting is and python as python
people you'll love this um how do you
have a general purpose worker and the
art the answer is that you use all those
features that we all love in python like
are um star args and star star kw args
and
uh the fact that functions of
first-class objects you can pass around
and stuff like that
so the way that in this task farm we
specify a task is we give it a tuple
which is the list of positional
arguments and we give it a dictionary
which is the list of keyword arguments
if any and those specify a task and when
we set up the worker we tell it what
function we pass in the function that
it's going to use to do the work and
then what the worker process does is
just calls f on
the
uh the the positional arguments and the
keyword arguments that you pass in the
task it splats them so it passes star
args and star star kwrx into the
function that does the work produces the
result and that gets sent back
um
and at the end we stop it so i would
love to go through this in in great
detail but i think we're not going to
have time but you'll you'll enjoy
reading the code it's really good and
you're
emlin has already probably turned it
into a
one that gets rid of all those gaps and
you know stuff but
um
this task foam is not quite the one that
i use i use a slightly more
sophisticated one but only a very
slightly more sophisticated one
um and i was going to show you some
timings so your exercise is to run the
task farm which just cubes the first
hundred numbers it's a stupid thing that
the tasks are much too small to benefit
from parallelism but it shows you the
thing there are some exercises for you
to do though uh in terms of um first of
all spit it so at the moment the code
just runs under a protected if if done
the name it calls done domain um extract
that into a separate file and run it and
check that you can use the task form as
a separate thing which you absolutely
should be able to write some better
functions some bigger functions and and
test whether it actually speeds up look
at whether reordering tasks from biggest
to smallest makes a difference in
general it should if they're different
sizes and use it for real on something
i use it mostly i have a huge bit of
code that is basically an entire
alternative approach to data science
that uses numpy but nothing else from
python and i have a set of tests about
2000 tests for it and i use a task form
to run those tests i use almost this
task form to run those tests
and the laptop that i'm running here
which is nate processor intel
laptop takes three minutes 23 seconds
203 seconds to
run the tasks in syria and if i run it
with task farm with
eight processors which is one controller
and seven workers so you wouldn't really
expect possibly go any faster than seven
times runs over five times as fast which
is pretty good
and if i run it on four processors with
only three works it actually goes 3.1
times
faster which seems literally too good to
be true but i didn't do multiple runs
and so on so it's probably just
performance variation and in fact if i
run it on my super computer at home my
20 processor mac studio
it runs in 10 seconds which is pretty
amazing uh that's on 20 processors
it only takes about 90 seconds if you
run it on one processor but that's still
you know 50 of the maximum possible
speed up you could expect pretty much
which is well worth having and 10
seconds is a lot better than 3 minutes
23 seconds to run a set of tests so
i'm quite pleased with that
test series and and the level of
parallelism here is i have a bunch of
different classes it's just using unit
test and each class is a task basically
and so in fact i can almost certainly
improve the speed up by breaking up the
biggest ones into smaller chunks so that
there's less
the version that i'm using is sorting
from biggest to smallest and that makes
a makes a difference so you've got the
code um
amdahl's law yes amdahl's law is
important amdahl was
there was a computer company called
amdahl that made competitors to craze
they were
they were not as good as craze but they
were pretty good um
uh so the um
amdahl's law says that the maximum
possible speed up is limited by the
longest sequential task so if you've got
hollowed tasks in task obviously if one
of them is going to take you know two
minutes by itself the whole thing can't
possibly take less than two minutes and
later in the mythical man month fred
brooks made the same almost same
observation saying nine women can't make
a baby in a month
there's a there's a sequential nine
months involved in in making a baby
um
so that's important so what i'm going to
do finally finally finally is talk about
the other form of parallelism in our
remaining
seven minutes
um
grid decomposition so with
there's often a kind of grid or mesh of
data over which calculations take place
so you know in physics that's like the
atmosphere or you know a block of earth
or a metal bar or an aircraft wing or
whatever um and in you know um ecology
it might be a you know the earth or
whatever or a national park or whatever
it happens to be
um
uh competition is often local because
physics is local um and even even
biology is kind of local actually um
typically there is quite a good degree
of enabling you only really need data
from from
where you're computing and a little bit
around it so breaking up that grid and
having a distributed memory system each
have a different part of the grid and
just communicate at the boundaries kind
of works
and so with grid decomposition usually
each process you usually just run spmd
every process does basically the same
thing exactly the same thing
and there's basically a step where um
you there's a bit of the grid that
you're responsible for you can typically
update the interior of the grid the bit
that isn't bound
at the boundary the interior uh you can
typically do
um
but to do the bits at the edges you need
to get information about what the
current state is of each of your
neighbors
so game of life a lot of you will know
game of life um
in fact i've included in here a nice
little um
copy of game of life i'm sure most of
you have seen it
um
so if i just run that so there's a game
of life running doing all those things
so you probably know game of life is a
cellular automaton
um
um
so cellular automaton uh so the black
cells represent so this is a grid the
black cells represent things that are
alive and the white things are dead and
there's an update rule to get you from
the pattern at time step t times t plus
one and that update rule is that you
count the number of neighbors that your
cells got so looking at all eight
neighbors the north the west east south
and the north west the southwest the
south east and the northeast and you
count them if the cell was alive at the
current time step then it'll still be
alive next time if the number of total
number of neighbors is two or three
if it's more than three it dies from
overcrowding this is supposed to
represent like a little you know
ecological system and if it's fewer than
two it dies of loneliness or
um something
probably not loneliness maybe it's from
not being able to mate i know um anyway
um
it does and if it's if it's empty then
it will come alive at the next cell if
there are exactly three
neighbours
just the updated roof of game life and
game life turns out to be touring
complete you can you can implement game
of life in game of life which is amazing
um this is me counting stuff i probably
counted it wrongly so the guy at the
back who counts things um
yeah it's probably wrong you can you can
mail me uh or not mail me um with a grid
decomposition uh you probably can't see
the red stuff but if you've got eight
processes you might chop it in you know
three that way and two that way sorry
into four vertically and two and then
you've all got a thing and then
all of these would have three well sorry
this one would have yeah this one would
have three neighbors to worry about this
one would have three neighbors to worry
about this one would have one two three
four five to worry about but if it was a
bigger grid and you had more processors
then some of them would be in interior
and they'd actually have eight neighbors
to
to worry about
um
uh it's quite often simpler just to
decompose in one dimension actually so
you have less interior there is the
downside but you have less communication
to do so it's swings and roundabouts
doesn't usually make a lot of difference
um we're not going to have time to do
this but you can imagine the boundary
communication stuff it looks like that
basically at each step you have to do
non-blocking stuff where you send your
boundaries to the relevant neighbours
and receive
the copy of their boundaries that you've
got
in your
in into your thing you compute your
interior and then when all that
communicate you then block to make sure
that all the communication is finished
and then you can update the boundary
layer and go again
again i
very impressed my keynote skills here
and i hope you are too
um
so this was this was when when i thought
this was a three hour class or when i
thought we'd get much further than we
did uh we were we were going to
parallelize this using gridly
composition uh but it turns out that a
brilliant thing for me to do is set an
exercise for you and the exercise is
parallelize this using a grid
decomposition
and i've broken it down into stages for
you um first thing you should do is so
that thing that i ran i'll run it some
more because it's it's so nice
um i've parameterized it for you too so
it's someone else's code i found it on
github uh there's a reference in the
thing uh we'll run it we'll run it with
um god i can't remember what you give it
uh we'll run it with 100 and then it'll
be bigger
um
yeah there you go it's fantastic isn't
it um
you've probably seen there are guns that
shoot pellets and there are all sorts of
things you can put in game of life you
can see things moving about and eating
each other and
all sorts of stuff anyway the basic
thing that i've suggested don't you know
what i suggested
it's written on the slides who's got the
slides um yeah so the rendering and the
updating are all just totally merged at
the moment in the code so the first
thing to do is separate those out and
have a bit that does the rendering a bit
that does the compute and then you can
do a very simple functional
decomposition where you do the compute
on one processor and the rendering on
the other see whether that goes faster i
have no idea whether it'll go faster
you'll have some communications to do
maybe it won't go fast because it's a
pretty simple thing
the whole thing is implemented in an
incredibly inefficient python and what
you should definitely do is replace it
all with numpy and if you do that
properly it will go a lot faster if you
do it by looping over the numpy array in
python it'll go slower not faster but if
you do it properly by actually using the
the python vector operations um then
it'll go faster and you need to think
about how to do that that's a good
exercise too
you should try breaking the grid down in
a grid decomposition and doing that that
communication i was talking about that's
really good exercise in learning the
blocking and non-blocking stuff
and exchanging the boundaries
and
i would not worry about updating the
display when you first do that first of
all just check it and the really
important thing said i should have been
saying right from the start but you all
know this because you're all good
professional python developers is for
god's sake write some tests so actually
the first thing to do is change this
thing starts with a random game of life
change it so that you can load an
initial state
check what it does in the serial version
check that you think the serial version
is right and then parallelize it and
make sure you get the same answer
because if you paralyze it and make it
go fast but it gives the wrong answer
it's not great
so there's the ex so i've taken the fact
that there was far too much stuff in
this and turned it into a virtue by
giving you an exercise i hope you all
appreciate that
uh other things we haven't covered we
are we're very close to the end i can
see you're getting very nervous but we
haven't covered dynamic process
management you can as i say instead of
using this mpi exact thing that doesn't
even work on some people's computers you
know bloody condor
you can actually just run python instead
i will be adding to this repo actually
i'll add a version of the task form that
does dynamic process allocation because
that's what i use i just it was too
complicated it's not very complicated
but it was too complicated for today
there's broadcast which is where you
send the same thing to everyone else in
a group of processors which is typically
all everyone there's scatter gather
operations where you send part of it to
everyone in the scatter and gather
partial results from everyone
to combine together or reduce type
operations which is the same kind of
thing but now you you know you sum them
or something on the way in rather than
just collecting them all uh all of
that's left all of these are documented
as hey i've got to improve what i regard
as improved versions you might regard as
degraded versions uh and we've
got to the end if not necessarily
through everything in
very nearly the time it's funny i had 91
slides and we've taken 91 minutes uh and
here's all the important stuff my
company stockastic solutions has a
website i'm also the chief data
scientist at smart data foundry which
you don't care about but it has a
website too
um the code from today is on github
there you can mail me i love getting
mail i ignore email but you know you
could mail me anywhere
um
you could link to me on linkedin i'll
i'll i'll probably say yes um
and oh and i tweet a lot with lots of
different handles and um it's all a lot
of it's [ __ ] posting so just just ignore
it um and the sides are still available
there and they're available in the repo
and yeah most importantly if you're
interested in this stuff and want to see
more i'm going to carry on working on
these examples i think and so i will
probably update the repo
if you
would like to him or do get in touch
either by following the repo or mailing
me or whatever
and i will probably put a grid
decomposition of game of life on there
and i'll probably put a
version of the task form that you can
run with python rather than mpi exec
both of which i think will be quite
useful
and if you find bugs if who found bugs
if you find bugs i love bugs well i
i love knowing about bugs
if you find solutions to bugs that's
even better pull requests things like
that thank you all for your time i'm
sorry it was all a bit random but
hopefully you got something out of that
go
you